marvel studios loki has introduced us to
all kinds of wild characters which is
why i'm speaking with vfx supervisor
brad parker hey brad hey there
now there are a ton of incredible
characters that you and your team got to
work on for the series
but i want to talk about one of my
favorites miss minutes how would you
describe her on the show
sure so miss minutes is this digital
mascot who appears to kind of provide
story exposition to talk to characters
to give them
information that they might not normally
have who kind of pops up
anytime she's sort of needed or wanted
or not wanted
as it can turn out to be from time to
time
she was a really interesting creation in
that
she wanted to look almost hand animated
she has almost a retro style
but she's fully three-dimensional like a
contemporary hologram
the visual artists that we worked with
on this created a series of tests
of what this clock person could look
like dimensionalized into 3d
and then we also did a series of tests
of what her
overall look or patina might be you know
she's got these sort of scan lines that
travel through her body
she's semi-transparent all of those
little elements
and decisions were things that were
painstakingly tested
and tested again until we arrived at
sort of a recipe
for what it is that missed minutes looks
like so once you have that recipe
how do you take the scene filmed with
real actors and added digital character
when you're working with a with real
actors who are interacting with
characters that aren't there
you generally want to make sure that the
real actors know where to look
and where the other character is going
to be in that case we provide
what's called eye lines that could be as
simple as a tennis ball on a stick that
the actors look at
in the case of miss minutes this was
often a
little led lamp that would create a
little bit of a kick of light
that she emanates from herself onto the
walls the actors were able to look at
that lamp and know that's where miss
minutes would be at any given moment
well speaking of blending the real and
the fantastic
let's talk about the time keepers who
are also very important to the tva
could you talk us through that scene
where we first get to see the
timekeepers in action
sure so the timekeepers were
particularly interesting in that they're
all digital they're meant to be
these sort of lizard-like
anthropomorphic
creatures that control the flow of time
and protect the sacred timeline now
they're entirely digitally created
they're hand animated and they're based
on a vocal performance by a single actor
which is pretty impressive
we soon discovered that they actually
are in fact
robots or androids and not living
breathing things so
it's an interesting challenge to kind of
create performances that felt like
robots pretending to be lizard creatures
that were ultimately kind of found out
all right that is layers on layers on
layers but once you have all of that
how do you take them from being more
humanoid and making them more robotic
in order to create the time keepers
digital sculptors will create
a version of a digital maquette or you
know small sculpture
in the computer we take it to the next
step which is adding texture you know
making sure the cloth looks real
that the material flows nicely and
has the proper amount of shine and that
their skin looks the way that it needs
to
and and their eyes and all of those
things are developed by
talented visual artists in the computer
we then animate
their performance this was a case where
we didn't do performance capture
animators hand animate all the movements
of the time keepers ultimately
everything is rendered
into the scene and compositors piece it
all together
and create one seamless effect well it's
all been such a sight to behold
now looking back at the entire series
what does it mean to you as an artist to
be a part
of the marvel cinematic universe it
means a lot as
a digital artist to kind of contribute
to
the marvel universe and introduce new
characters like miss minutes and the
time keepers
and you know to be able to kind of
identify what they look like
and how they behave and basically who
they are
is really exciting because you know that
that work is going to live on in the
future
thank you so much brad and of course
everyone go experience marvel studios
loki
only on disney plus
[Music]
you